it's fun  challenging and  sometimes  a bit  stressful  because  i might have forgotten a negative sign  or a certain decimal  and that gets me wrong  and once i find what my mistake was  i'm literally relieved because i learned  something new and i know to not forget  that again it really felt um like  i was  trying my best on something and then all  of a sudden it just  didn't really work because i missed one  little thing  so i had to like practice again and get  get it all right  it really  makes me feel like even if you even when  you make mistakes you learn from those  mistakes and  that  kind of really benefits you i think more  than actually getting the right answer  because you know like like you said with  sophia like you get that extra missing  puzzle piece